at first glance you might think that
these were photographs but these are
pencil drawings part of a growing art
movement called hyper realism
when people look at my drawings i would
love them to feel
a sense of emotion
[Music]
reality you know
using my works to bring people down to
earth
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is arisa stanley and i am a
hyper realistic artist
hyperrealism is a genre of art that
involves making drawings or paintings
that looks very realistic and you can't
actually distinguish it from a
photograph or reality
i started drawing when i was six years
old my dad owns a paper factory i
basically grew up around a lot of paper
when people see my works they are
usually shocked that is not a photo they
go like
oh wow
is that a photo did you make that with a
pencil and i'm like
yeah
usually my works take a long time to
create sometimes i can make a piece for
about a month sometimes it could drag
onto two months depending on my mood and
the size of the piece
[Music]
i like to use my works to speak on
issues affecting my society here in
nigeria and the whole of africa use the
voice that i have through my art to
speak for people who can speak for
themselves
this person is totally engulfed in oil
this signifies i want to use oil and
destroy our society
this signifies the see no evil
hear no evil and speak no evil i'm
encouraging people to take a step back
and try to emulate their childhood
trying to make people reset to default
when i pick up my pencil
and put it on paper it takes me away
it's something i can explain words
[Music]
you